um what I thought was dope was and I I
told wack this like I I appreciated him
being like a catalyst to kind of
deescalate what was going on between you
and the guys at okay I would be happy to
give wack credit for something like that
but in actuality that was entirely me I
just chose to have the conversation with
he didn't even that that was coming and
he was entirely antagonistic for the
most part so it's not like he really
helped out too much but he was my
sounding board for that convers kind of
helped guide the you know guide it a bit
you know he'd been talking to some of
them off camera and all that too so I
guess that probably helped yeah for you
I mean it feels like the it's it feels
like a lot more positive like this this
negative energy isn't hanging over both
of y'all's platforms you know do you
feel like kind of a relief since you
you've had that conversation on camera
and kind of like said I'm I'm going to
deescalate this I'm going to step back
yeah I think like at various points in
your career you have to be willing to
kind of zoom out look at yourself look
at what you're doing with your time and
I mean even just on a super basic level
I have this constantly where I'm
thinking about what I'm doing with no
jumper and it's kind of like well I'm
putting in this much time to earn this
much money from no jumper and in in some
sense I'm kind of ignoring my
opportunity with plug talk which maybe
is uh two or three times bigger
opportunity on revenue and when I zoom
out and I look at my my business and I'm
like oh well you spent a lot of mental
energy this week in arguing with people
and nobody benefits from this or seems
interested in this besides like the the
small little nest of Hardcore fans that
are talking about it on Reddit and stuff
it's not like all the the viral
platforms pick it up when I say
something you I me you had some good
rants I hit you like yo you you had some
[__] real Paul Heyman es WWE topnotch
yeah I got that in me but at the end of
the day it's just like like what is what
is the shelf life of this you know like
I can go viral doing all kinds of stuff
that doesn't like impact my life and
then when I saw the impact people around
you exactly I saw this [__] happening
with dub and it wasn't just like what
happened on camera with dub it's like
I'm having conversations with brick baby
and dub after the fact and there's just
things coming up in the conversation
about neighborhoods and about groups of
people and they're not getting along and
oh my God this might happen and [__] and
I'm just like looking at it and being
like okay you trying to make good
content on the internet result in a
situation that could very easily turn
bad and and even that situation could
spark 20 other situations it's just like
what is the [__] point why am I why
am I doing this over podcast beef yeah
and I realized in that moment I'm just
like well you know you could just kind
of like pull it back and just wave the
white flag and just take a little take a
little mini L right now to basically
spare yourself a lot of wasted energy a
lot of I think it's like growth I was
surprised that like even the audience
who obviously like wants to call me a
[__] and wants to point out me being a
[__] whatever they talked about it for
a day and then they were kind of over it
too because I think to a certain extent
like like in the early days of us
beefing that was the most viral content
on their platform and then this time
around it wasn't like it it may have
helped their content a bit they might
have got more views from it but it's not
like it was a you know nine months ago
where like the biggest clip on back on
fig that week is going to be talking
about me now it's it's just not really
having that impact and you know I see
Joe Buon and Rory and Maul still going
back and forth and just sort of like sub
dising each other and stuff all the time
and I don't know to me that seems kind
of silly like you guys have an
opportunity in front of you like why the
[__] is your energy still going into
this and granted it's not like all their
energy but they're still just kind of
doing the song and dance and it's the
exact same thing as us and to me I'm
kind of like you guys could probably
just not that like all of you guys have
kids all of you guys are fathers most of
us all of you guys are uh well obviously
I'm talking about like you know the main
guys involved everybody's got kids man
do know has yet to prove that he can
procreate I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure
he's he's he's all right I got a nut or
two in him shout out to duno but it you
know for me it was like just seeing like
some of the you know like I get it was
for entertainment but just I feel like
like once it kind of got past a certain
point it was like oh man like it almost
has to like be a thing you know but you
did a good job of like leaning into it
you leaned into that [__] for
real I think youed you said it kicked
off here yeah it did because I didn't
after they left the Channel I didn't do
any interviews I went on my honeymoon
Etc then I come back and finally you
asked me and I'm like okay I'll do an
interview with Kev and that I feel like
you kind of snapped into your your uh
you know what the big 22 thing yeah but
I didn't really like what I said didn't
really like compared to what was said
later what I said on here was like
nothing but it definitely like sparked a
lot of conversation uh have you heard
from Lush at all it looks like he's um
he's relapsed ah yeah I heard about that
I haven't uh heard from him uh lot lot
of people keep kind of hitting me up
asking if I'm want to have them on the
podcast and I'm kind of considering it
but yeah the the relapse thing was kind
of sad just because I had so many
conversations with him on camera about
him
basically moving uh you know or like on
camera him talking about how important
it was for him to not relapse and how he
couldn't really handle smoking weed or
he couldn't handle drinking from time to
time or taking xans or whatever he's cop
to so far so yeah that's a little so you
would be open to maybe maybe having him
on just to I'm definitely not angry at
him in the way that I was at one point
you know but am I dying to rejuvenate
his career by having a conversation with
him because as soon as I started to
think about it I pictured him going home
and immediately doing a five hour live
stream talking about what we just talked
about on the podcast and then throughout
the next week going on 10 other podcasts
to talk about the fact that he just did
a podcast with me and I don't
necessarily know that I want to be the
one putting the battery in his back in
that regard but it would be
it might help him heal though it might
help him
heal I feel like that's like a open
wound of his life because this the
biggest [__] that's ever come come up
for him yeah and he kind of fumbled it
you know he kind of [__] it up I think
that there was probably a time period
where if Lush had died I would have just
never said anything publicly yeah and
now I think that if Lush died I would
probably like tweet rip Lush so that's
growth that is growth that's a big step
right so who knows where we might be 6
months from now maybe I could actually
talk to him I don't know would you uh
ever I don't know about uh t-il but
would you ever entertain bringing ad
back on the podcast one day cuz it feels
like that's the one in relationship that
was I guess as less disrespectful in
terms of the commentary back and forth
ad kind of yeah that would probably be
plausible I wouldn't be super shocked by
that happening I think that they're
still kind of like ganged up over there
and they just don't I think that
probably if ad did that every everybody
else would be looking at him like he was
bugging and I think it's basically like
both of us trying to prove that not not
just both of us like me and AD but
really everybody's kind of trying to
prove that they don't need each other
right so I don't feel like I'm not
really in the position where I want to
like boost their [__] up by I'm not
talking about soon I'm talking about
maybe [__] a year from now yeah yeah I
mean I feel like honestly probably
someday we'll just like see each other
and end up in a conversation or somebody
there's already like people in between
us who kind of mentioned it of like oh I
could get you guys the phone or whatever
and I don't think either of us are super
eager to do it but I also has wack tried
no okay not so much maybe maybe to him
he doesn't really mentioned it to me
yeah I feel like Wax would be the guy
who would just be like I feel like he
would do it on camera though yeah like
I'm G call AD right now if he didn't do
it on camera he would go on clubhouse
and literally just tell everybody every
single thing that we talked about for
sure but uh yo is Clubhouse still
clubhouses I feel like it's wax house
now it's just it's just whack and like
10 other people I don't know he talks
about it like it's [__] huge but I've
realistically like almost never been on
there I I think the is that a pound of
mushrooms yeah I just had to ask I
couldn't tell if it was like pieces of
cardboard or it's uh obviously mushrooms
you put on pizza not anything of the
alite oh yeah Pizza mushrooms yeah I
[__] forgot that sitting there it's a
lot of yeah I me it's not that much that
would be a weird day right there eating
all of that if I that'd be a weird
[__] year eat a handful of that I'll
be on the moon